hey guys it's just jade and today is a
very
very exciting day we are about to unbox
a brand new custom pc
this was built by mods by ben who is an
incredible pc designer but also an
amazing photographer and he merges those
two passions together
on his instagram you guys have to check
it out he partnered with asus to build
this custom pc for me and i cannot wait
to open it up but before we do we're
gonna chat with ben and talk about some
of his inspiration behind this build and
also chris from asus
to tell us what's actually inside the pc
guys oh my gosh thank you so much for
joining me in this
zoom call here good to be here thanks
for having us hi chris hi ben okay so
ben do you want to do a quick little
introduction of yourself so that you
know my audience is a little more
familiar with what you've
been up to i've been following you on
instagram for a while now and honestly
your photography is so incredible
well my name is ben with mods by band
and i'm actually a
pc builder i do custom pc's
with asus uh so a lot of my stuff is
it's more water cooled so it tends to be
more
extreme than just a normal pc build i
work for asus i'm a part of the social
media team
and i do a variety of things i do a lot
of video work
uh some instructional videos and
long-form content
uh just a little bit of everything here
and we had actually met
in 2011 you said right
we did we were both entered into a
charity pc building race
through i believe it was tiger direct it
was really really fun it was so fun yeah
we had a pc building race and i was like
i don't think i'm going to beat any of
these people here i didn't come in last
so i appreciate your help so thank you
so much
glad to help and now here we are coming
full circle 2021
and i'm getting a new pc build and this
is really exciting because
i'd started streaming during the whole
pandemic again and
streaming was great but also you know
streaming on a pc
and then also gaming on the pc like i
was like man this this
is this is not ideal so the chat told me
that i needed to get a second pc
so that i'm able to stream in games
separately so this is
very exciting because now ben you have
been working on
a new gaming pc for me and this isn't
just like some normal
gaming pc that like i can just go and
pull off the shelf somewhere
this is all custom yes yeah it's all
awesome well
when we actually talked about it uh one
thing i did
wanted to try because um there's a
famous architect that i love so much
and the way he designs buildings it's
more of adding depth and creating like
different shapes and kind of stacking
them together
so basically i took that kind of same
concept with this pc build that i did
for you but i'm pretty excited i'm not
excited
what your uh first impression is
i cannot wait i mean is this something
that you've been doing for a while is
this something that you always wanted to
do like what's your main background
i love creating stuff that just kind of
out of this world
i'm more of a sculptor a modern sculptor
so basically i gather these parts
together and kind of create something an
art piece that's a sculpture but
you can also use it like you're going to
use it for gaming so
wait now obviously i know i have a
pretty tech savvy audience
they're going to want to know what is in
this thing so chris can you maybe walk
us through some of the components and
what we actually have inside of it
obviously the the motherboard is kind of
the foundation for that
and so we've set you up with an rog
maximus 12
formula z490 and what's really cool
about this
is something that i think ben probably
appreciated while building it
is it's already set up for water cooling
it also is coming with
an intel i9 processor so it's going to
be blazing fast for gaming
video everything you need the real crown
jewel of this build though
is you've got a tough gaming rtx 3090 in
it which is
the most highly sought after video card
that's on the market currently oh my
goodness
i'm so excited i've been trying to get
one and i had no luck at all so this is
so
cool this is gonna be an amazing
amazing build for you i think you've
also got 32 gigs of ram
a one terabyte m.2 nvme drive so
literally everything is just as fast as
you can get it right now
and best of all it looks amazing thanks
to ben's incredible work
i can't wait to see it it's downstairs i
haven't opened it yet so i'm just
waiting
patiently we've got one more special
thing for you that i'm not sure you even
know is on the way
and to take care of all of your your
gaming needs on pc
on console because i know you play some
console games we've got a 43-inch
4k display it is the world's first hdmi
2.1 display and it's going to do
up to 144 hertz at 4k
and it is just a gorgeous gorgeous
display
okay i have been stalking this since the
announcement
so i am so excited like i can't even
tell you
oh my goodness any day now it should be
there
oh man i am so excited well guys thank
you so
much chris ben i cannot wait to see
this thing i'm just i'm so excited i
can't wait so thank you guys
so i'm so honored that asus partnered
with ben to create this custom pc for me
and not only are the insides of this pc
incredibly powerful but this thing is
actually
a work of art like this isn't just your
everyday pc that you can pull off of a
shelf
this my friends is art let's open it up
[Music]
oh my goodness holy
molly i can't wait look at this cool
cable
why is this so pretty
oh my god this is i i cannot wait
it's so pretty
you guys freaking just look at this
thing like this absolutely
just feast your little papers on this
ben this is amazing it's so beautiful
hey there little rtx 3090
how you doing all of this acrylic is all
custom laser etched like this
this is this is art this is art
we also have a custom design keyboard as
well
well it's all unboxed let's go set it up
in my office
the pc is here it has not been turned on
yet i'm about to clear off this desk and
get the monitor all set up and finally
power this thing up for the first time
so this is my office i have my mac side
over here so this is where i do most of
my editing
and then over here on my pc side this is
where i game do all of my zoom calls
stream all of that happens over here so
i'm gonna have to really assess the size
of this monitor because this is not a
monitor this is like a television
this is like a full size i'm going to
the theater i'm in an imax theater now
and i'm watching a feature film
oh boy look at this thing
hold on a second
can you see me
[Music]
i mean it's gonna take up a pretty big
portion of this desk
the first thing i'm gonna do is just
clear everything out and start
fresh so clean
[Music]
we have everything set up i downloaded
some games i've got sea of thieves
running on the pc
i've got my playstation 4 hooked up i
also have my xbox
series x hooked up this is i'm in the
game
the thing that i also love is this
monitor also has speakers built into it
this is not a monitor this is a tv this
monitor is so
it's shocking it really is breathtaking
clothes crew i'm gonna just play by
myself look at my outfit though
wow this is beautiful it's beautiful
it's beautiful
what's up dude let's get it let's get a
freaking voyage gosh this looks amazing
i'm so i'm just like blown away like how
incredible it looks
oh i've missed the ladder i want to set
sail just so i can see how cool the
water looks
like look at this water it looks
beautiful okay so sea of thieves looks
amazing
now let's test out some call of duty
shall we
i'm so i feel like i'm in the
battlefield right now like honestly like
oh my
goodness what the heck
this is so beautiful oh come on
that was a nice shot are you hungry
do you wanna have a little dinner
okay well i didn't win i did very poorly
but it's been a while since i played
free free-for-all i must say
this is
shockingly beautiful i just remembered
when i was unboxing this that there was
a remote
control that came with this so i've been
playing sackboy
a big adventure a ton on playstation i
absolutely love this game
it's a great game for you know families
or
just yourself oh i have fallen
come here
get in there this looks so
freaking good have i said how incredible
this looks yet well thank you guys so
much for watching and a huge thank you
to asus and moz by ben for making
this entire project come to life i'm so
excited for my new setup this is going
to be so much fun and it's definitely
taking not only my gaming setup but also
my streaming setup
to a whole another level i'll put links
in the description for everything that i
talked about in this video and be sure
to go check out mods by ben he is
so incredible and so talented and huge
thank you again to ben
for creating this beautiful work of art
i'll see you guys in the next video
bye